ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome to
the Huberman Lab podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today, is an Ask Me
Anything episode, or AMA.
This is part of our
Premium subscriber channel.
Our Premium subscriber
channel was started in order
to provide support for
the Standard Huberman Lab
podcast, which comes
out every Monday
and is available at zero cost
to everybody on all Standard
feeds--
YouTube, Apple,
Spotify, and elsewhere.
We also started the
Premium channel as a way
to generate support for exciting
research being done at Stanford
and elsewhere-- research
on human beings that
leads to important
discoveries that
assist mental health, physical
health, and performance.
I'm also pleased to inform
you that for every dollar
the Huberman Lab Premium channel
generates for research studies,
the Tiny Foundation has
agreed to match that amount.
So now we are able to double
the total amount of funding
given to studies of mental
health, physical health,
and human performance.
If you'd like to subscribe
to the Huberman Lab Podcast
Premium Channel, please go
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
It is $10 a month to subscribe,
or you can pay $100 all at once
to get an entire 12-month
subscription for a year.
We also have a lifetime
subscription model.
That is a one-time payment.
And again, you can
find that option
at hubermanlab.com/premium.
For those of you that
are already subscribers
to the Premium channel, please
go to hubermanlab.com/premium
and download the Premium
subscription feed.
And for those of you that
are not Huberman Lab Podcast
Premium subscribers,
you can still
hear the first 20 minutes
of today's episode
and determine whether or not
becoming a Premium subscriber
is for you.
So without further
ado, let's get
to answering your questions.
The first question
is about fluoride.
And the specific question is,
why is fluoride in our water,
and how much is it harming us?
OK, well, that might seem
like a short question,
but there's actually a
lot to that question.
And I want to be very clear,
by posing the question, how
much is it harming
us, it implies
that fluoride is harming us.
And I'd want to be very clear.
The degree to which fluoride
can harm you or not harm you
depends on how
much of it happens
to be in the water or
toothpaste or some other thing
that you're consuming, OK?
So this is very important.
I don't want the question to
seem like a leading question
to imply that fluoride is
necessarily harming us,
because as I'm
about to tell you,
there are clear benefits of
fluoride for tooth strength
and for warding off cavities.
But if you get too much
fluoride into your system,
it is dangerous.
It is a poison at
certain levels.
So as you've probably
heard before,
the dose makes the poison.
So let's take this
seemingly simple question
and dissect it in two.
The first part of
the question was,
why is fluoride in our water?
And believe it or
not, even that is
hard to answer directly
because here's what's
happening right now in 2024.
There is a major lawsuit
in the state of California
to try and get fluoride removed
from the drinking water.
The outcome of that case is
still yet to be determined.
But the case was filed
by a group of individuals
who strongly believe that
fluoride at any concentration
in the drinking water is bad.
Why would they say that?
And what is their evidence?
And how strong is that evidence?
Well, there is some evidence
that if levels of fluoride
in drinking water exceed
a certain threshold,
it can cause problems with
thyroid hormone function
and perhaps even certain
aspects of brain function.
Again, if the levels
exceed a certain threshold.
So in the state of
California, there
is a major lawsuit
to try and get
fluoride removed from
the drinking water.
Now, at the same time,
meaning right now,
there is also a major lawsuit
in the United States--
this one taking place
in Buffalo, New York--
whereby citizens
are suing the city
because they insist
that there is not
enough fluoride in the water.
And they are suing for damages
based on the dental health
needs of their children that
did not, in their opinion,
get enough fluoride
in the drinking water.
So I'm telling you
about all of this
because the question, again, was
why is fluoride in our drinking
water?
And believe it or not, there
are certain states in the United
States, certain areas
of the United States,
where the fluoride levels in
the drinking water are low,
are zero, perhaps.
That's what the lawsuit
in Buffalo is about.
And by the way,
the city of Buffalo
may have now corrected
the amount of fluoride
in the water, taking it
from zero to something.
Whether or not it was actually
zero is still debatable.
But I think you're
starting to get the point,
that there is a wide,
wide divergence in terms
of how safe people
feel about having
fluoride in drinking water.
Some people want it
and are suing cities
because they feel there
wasn't enough of it
in their drinking water.
And others don't want any
fluoride in their drinking
water, and they're suing
cities because of that.
So this is a really barbed-wire
topic, as I like to say.
It's one that no
matter how close
you get to it, whatever
angle you look at it,
you're likely to get
stuck a little bit.
It's going to be a
little bit painful.
OK, why is fluoride in
some drinking water at all?
Let's set aside the levels
and just answer that question.
Well, in an upcoming
episode of the Huberman Lab
podcast about oral health.
I'll get into this
in a lot more detail.
But fluoride is a really
interesting compound
with respect to oral health.
And here's why.
Your teeth, believe
it or not, are always
in a state of either
demineralization
or remineralization.
Those are tricky words to say,
go ahead and try and say it.
Demineralization,
remineralization.
So I'm going to refer to them as
"demin" for "demineralization"
and "remin" for
"remineralization.
OK, your teeth are always
in one state or the other,
or one state predominates
versus the other.
Now, a cavity in your mouth
occurs when bacteria--
in particular,
streptococcus mutans,
sometimes called strep mutans--
feeds on sugars in
your mouth and then,
as a byproduct of
that feeding, creates
acids that then erode the
enamel and deeper layers
of your teeth.
In other words, it
demineralizes the tooth.
Now, I just told
you that your teeth
can be in a state of demin
or remin at any moment.
The way that your teeth remin,
the way they remineralize
and can potentially fill in
little cavities that have not
yet made it to the deeper
layers of your teeth,
is through a process that
involves the construction
of crystals from minerals--
that's why it's called
remineralization--
and get this.
This really wild.
These minerals
actually stack together
in very organized
little sequences,
kind of like LEGO blocks.
And the critical element
within those blocks
is something called
hydroxyapatite.
I love that it has the
word "appetite" in it
because we're talking
about oral health.
That's the normal process.
Fluoride was discovered,
not because it's a vitamin,
not because it's an
essential nutrient.
In fact, at high concentrations,
it's actually a poison.
I'll tell you a story about
that in a moment, where
I was actually poisoned
by fluoride at the dentist
when I was a kid, in large
part due to my own error.
Fluoride, it was
discovered, can actually
get inside of those LEGO
chain-like crystals,
the building of those, and
form bonds between them
that are actually stronger than
the hydroxyapatite bonds that
would normally form.
In other words, if you consume
fluoridated water or use
toothpaste with
fluoride, especially
if you do this when you're a
kid, what ends up happening
is that the crystals and
the mineralization structure
of the teeth becomes
ultrastrong, meaning
supraphysiologically
strong, which then limits
the ability for
that strep mutans
and the acid strep mutans
produces when it eats sugar
to erode the enamel
of your teeth
causing what we
refer to as cavities.
OK, so I went and asked several
dentists and a periodontist
about, why is fluoride
in drinking water?
Why is fluoride in toothpaste?
And they, of course,
gave me the explanation
that I just gave you, which is a
chemical mechanical explanation
or rationale.
However, most of the
things for our health,
such as the foods we eat, the
amount of exercise that we do,
are not naturally put into
our environment, right?
But tap water, which goes out
to everyone who consumes it
from the tap, is basically
a government or local
government-supplied resource.
And basically, the
rationale was--
and I believe this took
place first in the 1950s--
was, OK, given the potential
for fluoride to make
supraphysiologically
strong teeth, what can we
do to reduce the
cavities and tooth
decay that would occur in
children and adult populations?
Let's put fluoride in
the drinking water.
So that's what they did.
They did not do
this, I was told,
because it was necessarily the
best way to take care of teeth
and avoid cavities.
It turns out there are
a bunch of other things
that you can do, even if you
consume no fluoridated water
or toothpaste.
There are things that you can
do to enhance the mineralization
state of your teeth, even
fill in cavities, provided
those cavities haven't
made it into the deeper
so-called dentine
layers of the teeth.
I'll get into all of this
in that future episode.
But what the US and other
governments decided--
this, of course, varies
across the world,
to the extent to which there's
fluoride in the drinking water
or not-- was that by putting
fluoride in the drinking water,
they could prevent a
large amount of tooth
decay and cavities that
would otherwise occur.
It was, and remains, a
fairly low-cost approach
for these cities to introduce
fluoride to the drinking water.
And that's why fluoride
is in drinking water.
It is to try and create
supraphysiologically strong
teeth.
And, indeed, every
single dentist I
spoke to, including
functional dentists.
I spoke to periodontists.
I spoke to several
dentists, ranging
from, let's call them, more
"traditionally trained"
dentists to more, let's call
them, "alternative dentists."
All of them agree that at a
chemical mechanical level,
fluoride creates stronger teeth.
However, every
single one of them
also acknowledged
that the bonds that
are created in those
mineralization chains, as I'm
referring to--
I realize that's not
the technical term--
is not the normal hydroxyapatite
bonds that would form.
They are stronger than the
bonds that would normally form.
They are structurally different.
If you look at them down what's
called an electron microscope,
you'll see that they're
structurally different.
And some, not all of the
dentists, I spoke to said,
yeah, it would be
best to remineralize
the teeth to fill
in any cavities
that initially have formed--
again, not down to
the deep layers,
but they could still
be filled in naturally
through the building up of those
hydroxyapatite natural bonds.
But they acknowledged that many
people, perhaps most people,
don't take adequate care of
their mouths and their teeth.
So they understood the
rationale of putting fluoride
into drinking water.
And of course, that's
also why fluoride is
in many, not all toothpastes.
OK, so I'm hoping that
clearly answers for you
the question of why there is
fluoride in our drinking water
at all.
At least in most
American cities,
there is fluoride in
the drinking water,
although this
lawsuit in Buffalo,
I guess soon to be determined,
will probably tell us
whether or not, indeed,
there was a total lack
or a partial lack of fluoride
in the drinking water there.
I'm presuming that the
accusation is true.
But I don't actually
know that to be true.
I just know that there's
a lawsuit that exists.
If you Google that, you can see
some YouTube videos about it.
There's information
about this happening.
There are a bunch
of angry parents.
And I'm sure there are angry
parents on the other side.
And I don't know what the
kids are saying, but hopefully
no matter what, they're saying
them through healthy teeth.
OK, now, the second
half of the question
was, how much is the fluoride
in drinking water harming us?
I'm going to answer this
question very specifically.
The person asks, how much is
the fluoride in our drinking
water harming us?
Well, I already told you
ways in which it is helping
the strength of your teeth.
That's not debated.
Again, there might
be some dentists
that say, oh, the bonds
that are formed by fluoride
are different than the
ones that are naturally
created with no fluoride,
and so there might
be some debate about that.
But all of them acknowledge
that those bonds
and the mineralization
of the teeth
is stronger with fluoride.
They understand and
agree with the rationale,
even if they don't necessarily
agree with the practice
as the best practice.
How much is fluoride in
drinking water harming you?
Well, there are two
things you need to ask.
One is, how much fluoride
are you actually drinking?
Because it turns out
there's a tremendous range
of fluoride concentrations
in tap water,
depending on what
city you live in.
Now, I did an entire episode
of the Huberman Lab podcast
about water.
We talked about distilled
water versus spring water.
We talked about
hydrogenated water.
We talked about alkaline water.
We talked about all
of those things.
And we did talk about fluoride.
And one of the
key takeaways when
you're thinking about
fluoride in drinking water
is to know that if fluoride
concentrations in drinking
water are too high or--
and this is a very
important "or"--
you're consuming a lot of
a particular water that
contains even low levels
of fluoride, well, there's
the potential-- and, again,
I want to highlight the word
"potential" here.
I don't want to cause alarm.
That the fluoride is causing
disruptions to thyroid hormone
output or on the receptor end,
in other words disruptions
to thyroid hormone metabolism
and usage in the body.
OK, I want to be
really clear here.
I don't want people
to think, oh, fluoride
destroys your thyroid hormone.
It's the dose that
makes the poison.
It depends on how much.
Now, the Center for Disease
Control have set a recommended
level of 0.7mg/l of fluoride in
drinking water as the level--
and here I'm paraphrasing-- that
can help prevent tooth decay
and promote good oral health
and that they have deemed safe.
But if you want to know how much
fluoride is in your drinking
water, whether or not it is
above, at, or below that value,
you need to get your
tap water tested.
Now, fortunately,
there are websites
that can tell you
how much fluoride
is in your drinking water.
And if you trust the
data on those websites,
you can simply put
the city you live
in into one of those
websites, and you'll
get the information back.
I'll provide a few links
to those different websites
in the Show Note captions
for this episode.
We also provided those links
in the Show Note captions
for the episode on Water.
And then you can see.
Are you adjusting
the level of fluoride
in your drinking water
that's deemed safe,
less than that value,
or more than that value?
But keep in mind
that if you drink
a little bit, a moderate
amount, or a lot
of fluoridated
drinking water, you're
going to be consuming either
more or less fluoride.
Just because there's
a concentration that's
been deemed safe by the
Center for Disease Control
does not actually tell
you whether or not,
OK, if you're drinking half
a gallon of tap water a day
versus a gallon versus
just a couple of cups,
whether or not you
are in that safe zone.
And of course, this is going
to vary by body weight.
If you're a small child,
those lower levels of fluoride
are going to equate to a
larger total amount of fluoride
as seen by the
volume of the body.
If you think about
this, everything's
by body weight volume.
And this is why drug dosages
are most typically calculated
as a function of pounds or
kilograms of body weight.
Not everybody gets the
same dose of every drug.
And if you're a
very large person,
maybe you can tolerate
more fluoride.
As I mentioned before,
high levels of fluoride
have been shown to disrupt
thyroid metabolism.
It has also been
hypothesized-- again,
this is still highly
debated-- hypothesized
to be neurotoxic under
certain conditions.
That is, toxic to neurons.
It can kill neurons at
certain concentrations,
not necessarily
the concentrations
present in your drinking water.
A lot of the evidence that
fluoride is neurotoxic
is from so-called
in vitro studies.
So studies done
effectively in a dish,
although there is
some in vivo evidence
that it can cause a
neurotoxicity, a.k.a.
neurodegeneration.
So I think when it comes
to the topic of fluoride,
people tend to bin out into
not concerned and simply want
fluoride to strengthen
their teeth; mildly concern,
kind of keeping an eye on
this stuff-- you know, OK,
fluoride doesn't
sound great for me,
but as long as the
concentrations aren't too high,
some people will say, I've been
drinking tap water my whole
life and I feel great, my teeth
are strong, and my brain works,
and my thyroid seems fine--
and then people who are
very, very concerned
about fluoride at any
concentration in their drinking
water.
Hence, the lawsuit in
California and other lawsuits
around the country.
So I believe that when we're
talking about fluoride,
you really need to
think about the dosages.
And you need to ask yourself
which one of those three
categories you fall into.
Now, if you are
concerned about fluoride,
it does not necessarily mean
that you can't drink tap water.
The suggestion simply would
be to filter that tap water.
And during the episode
I did on water,
I talked about a number
of different filtration
approaches.
Many of those filters
will filter out fluoride,
and you can simply look
up water filters that
eliminate or reduce fluoride.
And then some people have
enough disposable income
and/or are concerned
enough about fluoride
in their drinking water that
they will purchase or create
very extensive, very
thorough filtration systems
to completely eliminate fluoride
from their drinking water.
So you'll find different
ranges of concern.
Again, aside from the data
of high fluoride levels
being disruptive to
thyroid hormone pathways
and possibly
neurotoxic, I personally
am somebody who filters the
drinking water I consume out
of the tap, unless that
is I'm going to boil water
with it for making things like
loose leaf yerba mate which
is one of my favorite
drinks, although lately I
drink this cold brew Mateina
yerba mate, which by the way,
is made with purified
water, no fluoride.
And so on and so forth.
But if I'm making rice
or I'm making pasta
or I'm making oatmeal and
I need to use tap water,
I don't worry about removing
the fluoride from that water.
However, if I'm
going to drink water,
if I'm going to mix an element
electrolyte pack in or just
drink a glass of water
or go out on a hike
and take some
water with me, I do
use a water filter, either a
filter that fills from the top
and then seeps down, the ones
you put in the refrigerator.
Or I recently purchased
a whole house filter
for the drinking
water taps in my house
so that it does remove
all the fluoride
and removes some other
contaminants as well.
So it's going to depend
on your level of concern,
and it's going to depend
on your disposable income
and any number of other things.
And I must say that
every once in a while,
I'll drink a little bit of
tap water out of the tap
without any concern about
filtering the fluoride.
I'm not somebody who gets hyper
concerned about these things.
But I do understand
why some people
do get hyper concerned about
these things, especially
people who've read up on
fluoride and some of the health
concerns of consuming
too much fluoride,
because I also find it very
logical and understandable
that as people
learn more about how
a particular substance might be
harming their brain or bodily
health that they will
become more concerned
about consuming that substance.
It just stands to reason.
So what am I suggesting?
I suggest that you figure
out how much fluoride
is in your tap water.
I suggest that you,
then, make a decision
as to whether or not
to filter that water
or not before drinking it.
And then, of course,
you have to make
a decision about what sort
of financial investment
you're willing to make
to filter that water.
You can find a list of different
price ranges of water filters
in the Show Note captions
in the Water episode.
You may also want to
watch that episode
and go to that timestamp.
And there's an
enormous range there.
I want to be very clear.
I don't have a
financial relationship
to any of those
filtration mechanisms.
Again, some people
have $0 to devote
to that process of
taking the fluoride out
of their water and
other contaminants.
Some people have many, many
tens of thousands of dollars.
So it really just depends
on your disposable income
and your level of concern.
But if you were to ask
me, I would say, yeah,
I think given that the cost
of most of the filters that
can remove most of
the fluoride is low,
and given that there is some
health concern of consuming
too much fluoride, why
not just remove fluoride
from the drinking water?
And then if you say, well,
won't that weaken my teeth,
then I would say, well,
watch the episode that's
soon to come out on oral health
because it's going to explain
a lot of approaches, including
fluoride-containing toothpaste
but some other
nonfluoride-containing
toothpaste and other
things that one
can do that the community of
professionally-trained dentists
all agree can really help
improve the mineralization
state of your teeth and, indeed,
can fill in cavities that have
begun to form but
haven't yet made it
to the deeper layers of
your teeth, and on and on.
Now, I do have a brief
story about fluoride
that I'd be remiss if I didn't
tell you, which essentially
shows that fluoride is
designed to strengthen teeth
but is also indeed a poison.
So when I was a kid, I had
a lot of dental issues.
I didn't consume much sugar.
My mother, fortunately,
was good about not letting
us consume too much sugar.
But for whatever reason, my
mouth was kind of a mess.
I'd brush.
I'd floss.
I would do all these
things, but I actually
had my adult teeth come
in behind my baby teeth,
so it didn't push
out my baby teeth.
So not only did I not
collect from the tooth
fairy, which I only recently
discovered isn't real.
But how would I know?
Because the tooth
fairy never showed up
because all of my adult teeth
came in behind my baby teeth.
So I had to have all of my
baby teeth pulled on the top.
So I did not have
a good relationship
to the dentist as a
location or a person.
In fact, they had to tell
me not to bite the dentist.
By the way, I haven't bitten
a dentist in a long time.
So hopefully, my dentist,
if watching this,
is not too concerned.
I do get twice a year cleanings.
I think every dentist agrees
that's a good thing to do.
Some people may need less.
Some people may need more.
But how do you know?
You need to go to a
dentist to find out.
Back to the story
about fluoride.
I started going to
the dentist quite
a bit because of all
these dental issues
that I had as a kid.
And what they used to do--
I don't know if they
do this anymore--
but what they used to
do is they give you
these little trays, which
are kind of like mouth guards
that you would use
for boxing or hockey
so your teeth don't
get knocked out.
And they would fill those trays
with this jelly-like stuff that
contained fluoride, and
they put it on the top
and on the bottom.
And the stuff just--
oh, little bits of it
would seep onto your tongue
and your throat.
And it was so sour.
It was so awful.
And they'd seat me
in this little wicker
chair in front of a television
and turn on cartoons,
as if that was supposed
to make me forget how
awful the whole experience was.
If anything, it probably just
created a Pavlovian conditioned
response to hate cartoons,
which I suppose did not work,
because I liked cartoons then.
I don't watch them now.
Truly, I don't watch them now.
So I sit down on
this wicker chair.
I've got the fluoride in my
teeth with these two trays.
And I'm just hating
this whole process.
I think I must have been
about five or six years old.
So I decide, in my
infinite wisdom,
to just swallow all
the fluoride paste.
So I start sucking it down
through these mouth guards.
I can feel it going back into
my throat, and it's sour,
and it's stinging.
It's awful, but I'm thinking,
OK, I'm just going to do this.
And I'm going to sit there.
I'm basically going
to beat the test.
And so I drink all
this fluoride paste.
And then, of course,
I got immensely sick
within about three minutes.
I stood up.
I turned around and puked
all over the wicker chair.
I think that was deliberate.
Actually, looking back,
it was deliberate.
And puke all over
the wicker chair.
My mom comes running in.
What happened?
What did you do to him?
She was very protective of me.
Thanks, Mom.
What did you do to him?
And then I said I just
swallowed the stuff.
They wanted to do it again, and
I stopped doing the fluoride
treatment at that point.
Why did I vomit?
Well, I vomited because
fluoride is, indeed,
a poison at high concentrations.
Now, do I tell you
that story to make
you afraid of giving your
kids fluoridated toothpaste
or fluoridated water?
No, by all means, do
what you think is best
for you and for your children.
For me, however,
I've made some effort
to avoid fluoride toothpaste.
I do go to the dentist, as I
mentioned, about once a year.
I confess, during the
pandemic, it was probably less,
as they were busy, and it was
hard to schedule, et cetera.
I've had very, very few cavities
in my adult life, hardly any.
And my gum health
is very strong,
et cetera, et cetera, largely
through taking on protocols
that I'm going to describe
in the Oral Health episode
and that were recommended
to me by friends
who are both dentists and other
friends who are periodontists.
Because, again, there
are a lot of things
that we can do to strengthen
our teeth in natural ways,
by building up those
hydroxyapatite bonds,
which are the natural
bonds that teeth form.
And yes, believe
it or not, being
able to reverse
some early-formed
cavities, as long
as they haven't
made it deep into the tooth.
Also things like using
a soft toothbrush,
because if you brush too hard,
if you take that approach
and you're going to brush
your teeth really hard,
get them really, really
clean, yes, you'll
scrape off all the biofilm,
you'll avoid tartar build up,
but you can really cause
some tenting of the gum
tissue above the teeth and those
little recesses back in there
where bacteria get in.
And there's now a lot of
really strong evidence showing
that some of that bacteria can
translate into cardiac disease,
can translate into
metabolic disease,
and maybe even into
some neurologic disease.
So it's serious stuff.
Oral health is one of the most
important areas of health.
And it's one of the
most overlooked areas
of oral health.
And I think people generally
fall into two categories.
And I'll use these
two categories
to frame up the episode on
oral health that's coming.
One category of
person seems really
bullish on their oral health.
They're like, keep my
teeth white and clean,
and they floss and brush
twice a day, every day.
And they use tooth whiteners and
mouthwash and all those things.
And the other category is
kind of blasé about it.
Yeah, I brush my
teeth in the morning
so that my breath
doesn't kill every person
I get into an interaction
with, and so on and so forth.
But in reality, both
the group of people
that are doing an
immense number of things
to try and keep their teeth
white and their breath fresh
are, yes, doing things that
are good for their oral health,
but also, no doubt,
damaging their oral health,
in particular the
oral microbiome, which
is absolutely critical.
And then of course,
the other category
of people that are
neglecting their oral hygiene
and are not taking mouthwashes
and things like that
are also damaging their oral
health but in different ways.
So during the episode
on oral health,
I'll spell out all the things
that you can do, most of which,
by the way are completely
zero cost, many of them
actually will save you money,
both in the short and long
term, and can really
help you improve
your oral microbiome, the
strength of your teeth,
and reduce the number
of cavities, maybe even
reverse cavities that
have begun to form
and are not too deep
into the tooth yet,
and in a really nice way, all of
that independent of your stance
on fluoride.
Thank you for joining
for the beginning
of this Ask Me Anything episode.
To hear the full episode, and
to hear future episodes of these
Ask Me Anything sessions, plus
to receive transcripts of them
and transcripts of the Huberman
Lab podcast Standard channel
and Premium tools not
released anywhere else,
please go to
hubermanlab.com/premium.
Just to remind you why we
launched the Huberman Lab
podcast Premium channel,
it's really twofold.
First of all, it's
to raise support
for the Standard Huberman
Lab podcast channel, which
of course, will still be
continued to be released
every Monday in full length.
We are not going to
change the format
or anything about the
standard Huberman Lab podcast.
And to fund research, in
particular research done
on human beings, so not animal
models but on human beings,
which I think we all
agree is a species
that we are most interested in.
And we are going to
specifically fund
research that is aimed
toward developing
further protocols for mental
health, physical health,
and performance.
And those protocols
will be distributed
through all channels, not
just the premium channel
but through all channels,
Huberman Lab podcast
and other media channels.
So the idea here is to give
you information to your burning
questions in depth and
allow you the opportunity
to support the kind
of research that
provides those kinds of
answers in the first place.
Now, an especially exciting
feature of the Premium channel
is that the Tiny
Foundation has generously
offered to do dollar-for-dollar
match on all funds raised
for research through
the Premium channel.
So this is a terrific
way that they're
going to amplify whatever funds
come in through the Premium
channel to further support
research for science
and science-related tools for
mental health, physical health,
and performance.
If you'd like to sign up for the
Huberman Lab Premium channel,
again, there's a cost
of $10 per month,
or you can pay $100 up
front for the entire year.
That will give you
access to all the AMAs.
You can ask questions and get
answers to your questions.
And you'll, of course, get
answers to all the questions
that other people ask as well.
There will also be some premium
content such as transcripts
of the AMAs and various
transcripts and protocols
of Huberman Lab podcast
episodes not found elsewhere.
And again, you'll be
supporting research
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
You can sign up for the
Premium channel by going
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
Again, that's
hubermanlab.com/premium.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]